Jamie Authorities say this is now
a criminal investigation.
Several fires raging.
Now down this street, smashing grab flash mob at a Nordstrom
police, the number
of homeless people on the streets and in shelter.
Medical treatment
for minors has surprise attack within Israel's borders.
People are for
holding fireworks.
And an angel of the Lord appeared to them
and the glory of the Lord shown around them
and they were filled with fear.
And the angel said to them, fear not for behold.
I bring you good news of great joy.
Well, good morning church.
If you are new to our church, my name is John.
I'm one of the pastors here.
Uh, it's an honor that you would come worship with us today.
Uh, we'd love to get to know you somehow
if you would let us do that.
There's an info desk out there in the lobby.
You can just go say hi to their, uh, to someone there.
And we'd love to interact with you
and help shepherd you and point you to Jesus.
Maybe you're not ready not to talk to anybody yet.
It's okay. There's a QR code in the seat in front of you.
You can fill that out virtually.
Uh, we'll contact you won't spam,
you won't sell your information.
Don't worry about that. But we would love
to just encourage you
and point you towards Jesus,
how you can grow in the Lord in that.
Uh, but again, it is an encouragement to gather.
Always great to gather as we inch closer to Christmas.
Last week, we looked at Mary's song
and talked a lot about what waiting for the Lord looks like
and especially for Israel, 2000 plus years ago.
What did that mean for them as they waited on the Lord?
Well, we also then saw how God came through,
how he brought redemption by taking on flesh
to become our savior, to live a perfect life
and then die, the death that we deserve for our sin.
Well, today we're gonna see another angle on that
as we study Zacharia's prophecy, uh, which would've happened
around the same time as Mary's song would've happened.
Uh, so turn with me back to Luke chapter one,
and we're gonna be in verse 67, uh,
through 79.
Bounce around a little bit.
Before that though, a little bit of the backstory here.
Zacharia was a priest at the temple
he had served for many years.
His wife Elizabeth, though,
had never been able to have a child.
And back then that was a big deal.
That was something that would've caused people in that day
to question God's blessings on them,
that maybe they weren't really faithful
and they were not having a child.
And so that was something that they looked at as,
as a negative for sure, even to the, even more than,
than we might see it as a, a hardship today.
But by this point in their lives, there was very little hope
because the way the scripture says it is
that they were both advanced in years.
That's just a really kind way to say old. Okay?
So you can use that when you go to Christmas
with your family, that you're, I'm just advanced in years.
Okay? Um, so there was little hope, uh, very, very little.
It says zero hope that there was gonna be any resolution
to their problem here.
Yet, in all of that, they were both
faithful in following the Lord.
They were following him in every way that they could.
And on one particular day, Zechariah was chosen at random
to enter the temple and burn incense.
Now this was a big deal, uh,
because at at that time some priests never got to do that.
So they put the names in a hat you might think
and pull out one at a time.
And, and the most you could do it was once in your life
because then they would take your name outta the hat
and that was your chance.
And so this was already a, a sense of anticipation
for Zechariah as he was chosen to go into the temple
to burn incense that particular day.
But something even more spectacular happened
while he was in the temple.
This is back up in verse 11.
There appeared to Zechariah, an angel
of the Lord standing on the right side
of the altar of incense.
And Zechariah was troubled when he saw him
and fear fell upon him.
But the angel said to him, do not be afraid.
Zechariah sounds like what he said to Mary.
We saw last week, do not be afraid.
Zechariah, for your prayer has been heard.
And your wife, Elizabeth will bear you a son
and you shall call his name John and you will have joy
and gladness and many will rejoice at his birth
for he will be great before the Lord.
And he must not drink wine or strong drink.
And he will be filled with the Holy Spirit,
even from his mother's womb.
And he will turn many of the children of Israel
to the Lord their God.
And he will go before him.
We don't know who him is yet, but before him in the spirit
and power of Elijah to turn the hearts of the fathers
to the children and the disobedient to the wisdom
of the just to make ready for the Lord a people prepared.
Now, this is the same angel that God sent to Mary
to tell her about a miraculous birth.
He sends that same angel to Zechariah to tell him
that baron Elizabeth was also going
to have a miraculous baby.
Mary heard from that angel about Jesus.
Well, Zechariah hears from that same angel
that this one is going to be John the Baptist, that
Elizabeth is going to bear a son
and they have to name him John.
Now that was overwhelming to begin with an angel showing up.
But Zechariah initially, he doubted
what this angel told him.
He looked at his circumstances
and said, well, how can that be?
I mean, we're both old, right?
So he doubted
and God disciplined him by making him mute,
meaning he can't speak.
But in the same breath, the angel reminded Zechariah
that God sent the angel to proclaim that message
that it was God's word.
So you should not doubt this zacharia.
Well, he did. And yet he comes outta the temple
and people obviously know something has happened
because he can't speak and he's trying to make these motions
and they didn't have sign language yet.
So he's figuring out how to tell people
what happened, but they don't know.
So eventually everybody just goes home.
Well, lo and behold, soon
after that day, his wife, Elizabeth, conceived
God had fulfilled his promise, right?
Like just as a sidebar, why do we ever doubt that he's going
to, but we do all the time.
Of course. And so nine months go by,
Elizabeth is pregnant.
She's, she's growing of course in Zacharia the whole time.
He still hasn't been able to talk.
Well, Elizabeth gives birth to this baby boy and
and they're custom at the time was
to name the child on the eighth day.
So everybody gathers for this big celebration, this big
procedure process, whatever you would call it.
And everyone just assumed that that baby was gonna be named
after Zacharia his father.
'cause that's what they did. Well watch what happens.
This is starting in verse 60 now,
but his mother answered, this is Elizabeth,
his mother answered, no, he shall be called John.
And, and they said to her, none of your relatives is called
by this name, meaning you're not following custom.
And they made signs to his father, to Zechariah inquiring
what he wanted him to be called.
And Zacharia asked for writing tablet
and wrote, his name is John.
Now. Now notice something before we go forward.
He had somehow communicated to Elizabeth
that the baby was supposed to be named John, right?
He couldn't speak, but he communicated, he,
he got her to believe.
So she said it, John, he says it by writing it down.
And everybody wondered, why, why John?
And immediately verse 64, immediately his mouth was opened
and his tongue loose and he spoke blessing God.
We'll see what he said here in a moment.
But fear came upon all their neighbors
and all these things were talked about
through all the hill country of Judea.
All who heard them, laid them up in their hearts saying,
what then will this child be for the hand of the Lord was
with him, right?
Everybody's amazed by this
because God clearly had worked
as Zacharia had overcome his doubt.
He instructed his wife that they overcame their doubt.
They saw God do miraculous things in their lives.
And when he took the step of obedience to name the child,
John, notice what happened.
God opened his mouth again.
And what did he say when he finally opened his mouth
where he could finally bless God
because he, he'd been storing it up for so long,
he wanted to bless God.
Well, in fact, that's what this has been called over the
many centuries, this like we saw last week with Mary.
The first word in the Latin language was Magnificat magnify.
Here the first word is benedictus in Latin.
That's what this one's called
because his first word is blessed be the God
and Savior of our like.
Like blessed be God here. You'll see it.
Blessed be the Lord God.
This is what he wants to do is he can't just help
but spill out blessing.
And that's gonna be our main passage today.
Starting in verse 67, what did Zechariah prophecy
prophesy in, in light of
what he'd received from God all that he'd seen.
Here's what he prophesied.
His father Zechariah was filled
with the Holy Spirit prophesied, saying,
blessed, there it is.
Blessed be the Lord God of Israel.
For he has visited and redeemed his people
and has raised up a horn of salvation for us in the house
of his servant David, as he spoke by the mouth
of his holy prophets from of old,
that we should be saved from our enemies
and from the hand of all who hate us,
to show the mercy promise to our fathers
to remember his holy covenant, the oath that he swore
to our Father Abraham, to grant us
that we being delivered from the hand
of our enemies might serve him without fear and holiness
and righteousness before him.
All our days. And you child talking about John,
you will be called the prophet of the most high for you,
will go before the Lord to prepare his ways
to give knowledge, salvation to his people, the forgiveness
of their sins because of the tender mercy of our God,
whereby the sunrise shall visit us from on high
to give light to those who sit in darkness in the shadow
of death to guide our feet into the way of peace.
So here's the interesting thing about his prophecy here.
He actually talks about both children.
He's not just talking about John,
he's not just talking about Jesus.
He's talking about both miracle babies, John
and Jesus, the prophet of the most high and the most high.
The one who's preparing the way and the way, right?
So he, he's saying about both of them.
And so first our, our challenge here is
to understand John's role in redemption in this whole thing.
'cause Zechariah is prophesying about miracle baby
one, miracle baby two.
And so, so what's John's role here as Zechariah,
his father is prophetically describing what is happening.
John's birth was miraculous.
Jesus later said, no one's greater than John.
So what's the deal here? How do we understand John's role?
Well, first John was chosen by God from
before he was born, to fulfill Elijah's prophetic function,
to fulfill Elijah's prophetic function.
This is what we saw. Whenever Zeer is in the temple,
the angel's talking to him.
What does he say? Verse 15, he will be filled
with the Holy Spirit, even from his mother's womb.
He will turn many of the children
of Israel to the Lord their God.
He will go before him. That's talking about the Messiah.
He'll go before him in the spirit
and power of Elijah to turn the hearts of the fathers
to the children, to the
and the disobedient, to the wisdom of the, just
to make ready for the Lord a people prepared.
So Elijah, who was he?
He was a preeminent prophet in the Old Testament.
He was one that was seen al in many ways as a model prophet
where he did battle with Ahab
and Jezebel up on the mountain.
That's a great story. Go read that.
But, but he was seen as a model.
And so in fact, he was so prevalent that he didn't even die.
God took him to heaven in a fiery chariot.
So what often happened later in Israel's history is they
would think, oh, here's this prophet.
Maybe that's Elijah coming back.
Maybe that's Elijah not even reincarnated,
he just coming back 'cause he never died in the first place
they thought that of John.
Now John was very clear. Jesus was clear.
That's not Elijah reincarnated.
But notice what the angel said.
He was coming in the spirit
and power of Elijah,
meaning he's coming just like Elijah
came with the same power.
Elijah came with and remember what Elijah's goal was?
His goal was to prepare the way of the Lord.
That's what every prophet was to do, was try, try
to ready the people to
understand and believe in the Messiah.
So his job was that John came in the same way.
In fact, this was predicted at the end of the Old Testament,
the last two verses of the Old Testament.
Malachi four verses five and six.
Behold I will send you Elijah, the prophet before the great
and awesome day of the Lord comes
and he will turn the hearts of fathers to their children
and the hearts of children to their fathers.
Lest I come and strike the land
with a decree of utter destruction.
Does that not sound familiar?
That's what the angel said John's gonna do.
John's a fulfillment of this passage, which is a fulfillment
of Elijah and the prophetic vision
of him being the forerunner of Messiah.
Now remember, up until this point, God had been silent
for 400 years.
No prophets, no words.
Everybody was just kind of floating through it all hoping
but 400 years of silence.
And then John shows up carrying the mantle
of the prophetic vision of Elijah.
That's a huge deal
because they would've known Malachi four, five, and six.
They're saying, okay, something's different about this guy.
Maybe now's the time that the Messiah is going to show up.
That's what he did, right? He prepares the way.
We'll see in a second prepares the way of the Messiah,
calling people to repent, to ready their hearts for Christ
and all that he would bring turning hearts,
turning people to the Lord.
But it wasn't hear, this wasn't just proclaiming repentance,
it was also proclaiming Christ
and that he would bring saving forgiveness when you repent.
It wasn't just a generic repentance
that you hope, man, I hope this works.
It was repentance to forgiveness
and that forgiveness comes in the Christ.
Remember, that's what Zechariah prophesied John was going
to do as a prophet in verse 77, to give knowledge of
salvation to his people in the forgiveness of their sins.
That was part of the deal.
In fact, that's what Mark one four
through eight says, John did.
But notice how John viewed himself
in relation to this Messiah.
John was a great, and Jesus said great,
and John was miraculous, but but notice John's perspective.
John appeared baptizing in the wilderness,
proclaiming a baptism of repentance
for the forgiveness of sins.
All the country, Judas, Jerusalem were going out to him,
being baptized by him in the river, confessing their sins.
John was clothed with camel's hair
and wore a leather belt around his
waist, ate locusts and wild.
Honey, I'm sure glad
that's not the same thing anymore, but he preached.
Notice what he says
after me comes He who is mightier than I, the strap
of whose sandals I'm not worthy to stoop down and untie.
I've baptized you with water,
but he will baptize you with the Holy Spirit.
Like John great, amazing forerunner of the Messiah.
And he looked at it like, no, no, no. That's about him.
In fact, John won later he makes it even more clear
at Jesus' baptism.
He says, the next day he saw,
John saw Jesus coming toward him
and said, behold the lamb of God
who takes away the sin of the world.
This is the one of whom I've said
after me comes a man who ranks before me
because he was before me.
Meaning he existed before me.
I myself didn't know him,
but for this purpose I came baptizing with water
that he might be revealed to Israel.
Right? You see that John's purpose was
to point to Christ.
He wanted to let Israel know that salvation had come.
But it, it's not the same as you might think, Israel.
You've been waiting for a political messiah,
freedom from Rome, get your land back.
Salvation is not merely political.
Salvation is not merely social.
He's saying to them in this salvation, first
and foremost is a problem internally
that you have, it's called sin.
That's what you need to be saved from.
First and foremost,
even looking at all the temple sacrifices throughout the
generations should have pointed them to the true lamb
of God, the spotless one
who could take away their sin forever.
He's saying, guys, this is it. He's here.
Look, the lamb of God is here.
So that was John's role.
He, he was solely focused on
pointing the way to the Messiah.
He must increase, I must decrease. That's his heart.
But that good news of great joy that he was proclaiming
should now lead us to,
to more deeply look at God's role in redemption
according to Zechariah.
So John's role, we saw it's clear from this passage
what he's supposed to do, but,
but Jesus was greater than John.
So let's focus on him. What did God do?
What is God doing in redemption?
What we learned first here is, is
that God fulfills the prophecies.
That's the first point
that we see about redemption in God's role is
that he fulfills the prophecies.
This is just like we saw last week with Mary's song, a lot
of references to the Old Testament, the promises God gave.
You see it even here, verse 70, God spoke about this horn
of salvation from David's house that's prophetic.
The holy prophets of old verse 71
to save them from their enemies.
That's all predicted.
Verse 72, God did all this to show his tender.
Mercy promised to their fathers,
God remembered his covenant prophetic language.
Verse 73, God swore an oath, a promise to Abraham
again and again throughout history,
that God would deliver his people.
This is all God taking these promises.
And when Jesus shows up, hundreds
of prophecies were fulfilled
and many, many more will be
fulfilled in the future through him.
So, so what he's saying in this is, God, you can trust this.
You can trust that I'm coming through for salvation,
but you can trust that all the promises I'm making
for you will also be fulfilled.
Maybe not in the way you want or think,
but they will trust me.
So God's role in redemption first is
to fulfill his promises.
But there's one specific way God does that.
Zacharia says it's by delivering his people.
God delivers his people.
And that's verse 74 specifically, which
actually recalls the exodus in the Old Testament.
You remember when, when Moses goes up
to Pharaoh, God told him to do this.
Moses goes to Pharaoh
and he demands that God's people be released from
the slavery they'd been in in Egypt for 400 years, right?
He goes up to to Pharaoh and what does he say?
You know this Charlton Hesston, right? Let my people go.
But that was not all He said, if you remember, he said,
let my people go.
But what else did he say
that they may serve the Lord in the wilderness?
There was a reason. Let my people go
so they may serve the Lord in the wilderness.
Now listen again to what Zacharia said in Luke chapter
one, verse 74.
He says that we being delivered from the hand
of our enemies might serve him without fear in holiness
and righteousness before him all our days.
And so God's giving a physical illustration here
of the deliverance of his people from the land of Egypt.
He's saying to them now, in this context,
I'm gonna do it spiritually.
What you saw happen, what you remember
and recall happening from ex, from the Exodus narrative,
it's gonna happen spiritually too.
You're gonna be saved from your enemies, the enemy
of sin mostly and be free to serve me.
So God delivers his people in redemption.
That's what he does for us.
There's another piece of this.
He shows us, Zachariah does
that God provides the light we need in redemption.
He provides light that we need.
Look again at the last two verses 78
and 79 here, Whereby the
sunrise shall visit us from on high to give light to those
who sit in darkness and in the shadow of death.
Now, if you know your timeline, you know that at this,
this point when Zechariah is saying this,
Jesus has not been born yet.
That's actually the next chapter.
And so though the dawn was beginning to glimmer
in the eastern sky, the sunrise hadn't happened yet.
'cause the sunrise we're talking about the savior Messiah.
It hadn't fully come yet,
but you're starting to see glimpses.
You're starting to see things happen
like you see in the morning, right?
You start to see some lights shining a little bit brighter,
but you don't see the sunrise until a specific moment.
That's what we're still waiting for.
Now here's, here's part of just biblical theology,
understanding darkness.
When you understand darkness in God's word,
it's used all over as a stand-in for sin, for evil,
for lostness, it's used as as a way
that people are talked about.
Where they are separated from God.
They're living according to their own flesh.
That's darkness that happens all over God's word.
Now that is partly external
that it's just we live in a dark world and
and listen, it doesn't take very long to look
through the news or to scroll through your social media
and see that this is a really dark place.
And so there's a bit of darkness that's external to us.
We understand that. But really also there's an internal
reality of darkness.
All of us, Romans 1 21 says,
although they knew God, they did not honor him as God
or give thanks to him,
but they became futile in their thinking
and their foolish hearts were darkened.
That's you and me, every one of us.
That's why we needed this light, this sunrise
as Isaiah nine verse two promised 700 years
before Jesus came, the people
who walked in darkness have seen a great light.
Those who dwell in a land
of deep darkness on them has light shown.
But here, here's what I know. I've thought of.
This is kind of my thought process.
I know others have as well.
When we hear the word sunrise, we tend to think
of something very pleasant, don't we?
Like you think of on your back porch, it's a nice morning.
You got your Bible out.
You see deer kind of traipsing through your backyard
and the sunrise is just beginning to creep up.
You got your nice warm co, I mean tea there with it and,
and it's just like you know you.
You see this sense of of pleasant. This is peaceful.
But if, if this darkness is so pervasive,
that kind of a sunrise would not have anything to do
with overcoming this kind of darkness, right?
Sunrise is pleasant in our minds, but, but watch this.
Listen to the rest of Isaiah nine
after what he said in verse two, verses three through seven,
that light right has come.
You have multiplied the nation, you've increased its joy.
They rejoice before you as with joy at the harvest
as they are glad when they divide the spoil Now.
Now we're doing okay at this point still sitting on the back
porch, Instagramming our quiet times, right?
So let's feel good. But then verse
four, for the yoke of his burden
and the staff for his shoulder, the rod of his oppressor,
you've broken as on the day of Midian,
for every boot of the tramping warrior in battle tumult
and every garment rolled in blood will be burned
as fuel for the fire.
Oh, for to us, a child is born to us.
A son is given. The government shall be upon his shoulder,
meaning he's taken over
and his name shall be called wonderful counselor,
mighty God, everlasting father, prince of peace, of the
increase of his government and of peace.
There will be no end on the throne of David over his kingdom
to establish it, to uphold it
with justice, with righteousness.
From this time forth forevermore, the zeal of the Lord
of hosts will do this.
And so the sunrise shows up
and it's not all Instagram pleasantries,
it's battle to bring peace.
Who's he battling? He's battling his enemies.
So the sunrise shows up
and it's not just this kind
of peaceful little candle in a cave kinda light figure.
It is this blazing SUN sun coming
to drive away every shadow and every sorrow
and every sinfulness that's in the world,
every one of his enemies.
That's what the sunrise is.
It is fear inducing for those who are in darkness, for those
who are walking in darkness.
Not, not those, those of us who are in darkness,
but we see the light.
It's those of us in darkness that don't see the light
and are walking in darkness and enjoy it.
And we see that's what we want.
Where his enemy, we don't have peace with God.
That's what he brings. It's bad news.
And so that salvation, that redemption is both external.
That because the Lord is my light,
my salvation, whom should I fear?
And we should have no fear of anything
because he is that light.
But that's also an internal reality of his
walking us into that light, which is what Acts chapter 26,
verse 18 actually says that God sent Paul
to open their eyes so they may turn from darkness to light,
from the power of Satan to God
that they may receive forgiveness of sins in a place
among those who are sanctified by faith in me.
It's what Jesus said, John eight 12,
I am the light of the world.
I am the sunrise. Whoever follows me will not walk
in darkness but will have the light of life.
Okay? The sunrise is here. How are you gonna respond?
Is basically what he says.
You got life, you got light if you're in me.
But you walk in darkness and you see what happens to that.
And so when he comes into a life, the light of life comes in
and and that that light drives away darkness
even inside your heart.
And what that is, is a foretaste of that blazing glory
that he's going to come burn away all the darkness once
and for all someday in the future.
What he does in us now is a glimpse of
what he's coming to do someday.
He brings the light we need.
But here's what that light is intended to do.
Zechariah actually says it this way in Zechariah one, uh,
Luke 1 79, the very last verse, very last phrase,
this light comes, it says
to guide our feet into the way of peace.
God leads us into peace. This is redemption.
This is part of redemption. He leads us into peace.
Now, they would've seen that freedom from oppression.
No more Rome. We get our land back.
But we can also understand today
that the king values God brings through his people.
That's peace on earth. Yes.
And that's coming one day forever.
We can praise the Lord for that.
But more importantly, it's a peace with God.
He brings peace, leads us into peace. We are enemies.
We're opposed to him. We're in the darkness
separated from him.
Yet Romans five, one, since we've been justified by faith,
we have peace with God through our Lord Jesus Christ.
Forgiveness an enemy now a child,
his perfect life, substitutionary death,
victorious resurrection makes you a child of God instead
of an enemy of God gives you peace
with God when you place your faith
specifically in Jesus's work for you.
That's good news of great joy.
But That brings up the last piece
of zechariah's prophecy here.
We saw John's role, we saw God's role.
What's our role in redemption?
What's the role we play in redemption?
Well, here's a short answer. Nothing.
This is all of God, right?
This is, this is clear from this whole passage
as you work through this.
God visited God redeemed.
God promised God provided God showed mercy.
God made the covenant. In fact, the universe, 73,
notice it says, God granted us.
That means it's a gift.
Then verse 74, that we even the tense matters
that we being delivered.
That's passive, right?
That's not like you delivering yourself.
That's you're sitting here, you're being delivered
like the claw and toy story.
You get chosen, right? That's being delivered.
God does it. You see, God sent the sunrise.
God gives light to those in darkness.
God guides our feet into the way of peace.
What that means is that this is all of grace.
This is all of grace.
Redemption's a gift
because he loves us even though we don't deserve it,
God gives us grace.
It's what Ephesians two says.
So well, even including the faith element,
we might wonder about Ephesians 2, 8, 9.
For by grace you have been saved through faith.
And this is not your own doing.
It is the gift of God, not a result of works so
that no one may boast.
Romans 11 says, if it's by works, it's not by grace anymore.
This is a gift. It's by God's grace alone.
You can't earn it because if you could earn it,
you would start boasting about it that you were the one
who figured it out or you were in this small subset
of people that were good enough to earn it.
No, you cannot earn it. So you can't boast about it.
It's just like this holiday season.
So check this out, workspace salvation is
everywhere right now.
And I'm not just talking theologically.
I'm talking about when you talk about presence
or coal in your socking, what's the question?
Have you been a good boy? Have you been a good girl?
Oh, You're gonna get coal or you're gonna get presence.
That's works based salvation, isn't it?
It's it's subtly feeding into this reality that we have
to earn it some way.
That's not how this works. You get the gift of redemption,
even though you could not be good enough at all
when you place your faith in the fact that Jesus
was good enough for you, that's when you get presence.
You're completely deserving of the coal. Absolutely you are.
But he was good enough for you.
And you say, he's good enough for me.
I'm placing my faith in him. And you get presence.
It's grace. It is grace.
Good news of great joy, right?
But I want you to see something about that grace.
It's for a purpose that grace is for a purpose.
We already saw the exodus motif come out again in verse 74,
that image of God delivering his people for a reason.
Did you see why he did it?
Why did God deliver his people from Egypt?
Why does he deliver his people today?
It's the same reason verse 74,
that we being delivered from the hand
of our enemies might serve him without fear in holiness
and righteousness before Him all our days.
Listen, God's redeeming deliverance is not
so you can have a cushy life.
It's not that you can have everything you would ever want.
It's so that you would serve him freely now
and you're not enslaved to everything you were before.
You're free. You're free from the fear
of the enemy being able to touch you anymore.
You're free from the reality that God might cast you away.
You don't have to worry about anymore.
You're free to live a life fit for him
and empowered by him to follow him.
You're saved to serve.
You are freed from your sin to be a servant to God.
And that's notice all your days, he said
that was in there all your days.
That means there is no retirement age in serving the Lord
All your days and hear me, kids, students,
there's not a minimum age either.
All your days, zero to
however long you live, all your days saved
to serve the Lord freely.
And there's one primary way we do that
by being a carrier of that light to the dark world
around us might think of it this way.
It's kinda like you're carrying the flashlight. Now.
I'm not gonna turn on 'cause you're blinded. You're right.
You are not the SUN son.
You're not the son we've already seen all morning.
That's Jesus, right? That's the sunrise. He is the son.
But, but listen to what Jesus said about you now believer.
This is Matthew five 14 through 16.
He says, you are the light of the world.
A city set on a hill cannot be hidden,
nor do people light a lamp or turn a flashlight on
and put it under a basket, but they put it on a stand.
It gives light to all in the house.
In the same way, let your light shine
before others so that they may see your good works
and give glory to your father who is in heaven.
And so check this out. The light has made you
a smaller light so he can shine brightly through you
and he gets the glory Like your light is not focused on
anything but like spotlighting him
as you live the life, as you empower,
as he's empowered you to live this life.
You're just constantly pointing to him.
Now, what else are you doing? You're also, in a way,
as you carry this light, you're helping to guide others into
what that verse said, the way of peace that you're on.
You see how that works? People are walking in darkness.
You have the light of the world shining through you
so you can help guide someone else into that way of peace.
Now, I'm not just making that up.
That's what second Corinthians five actually says in a way
for us to understand how to do this, that we are to do this
and we hear the word reconciliation,
think peace with God here.
Therefore, if anyone is in Christ, he's a new creation.
The oldest passed away, the new light has come.
All this is from God.
Grace who through Christ reconciled us to himself,
gave us the ministry of reconciliation that is in Christ.
God was reconciling the world to himself,
not counting their trespasses against them, entrusting
to us the message of reconciliation of peace with God.
Therefore, four, because of that reconciliation,
we are ambassadors for Christ.
God making his appeal through us.
We implore you on behalf of Christ, be reconciled to God.
So see this church, God's promise,
deliverance was all of grace.
You can't light this thing up yourself.
God gave it to you by his grace. We don't deserve it yet.
He gave it anyway. And it was for a purpose.
It was to serve him as a new holy
creation without fear, where we're now his ambassadors
of light in a dark world around us.
That's what he gave us the gift to do.
And so may that be true of US church.
May we be transformed,
light bearers different in the way we live,
living scent, carrying that light to everyone around us.
May that be so church.